après avoir lancé dans l'espace des rats
et des chats la france se prépare et y
envoyer des singes c'est le médecin
commandant chatelier du centre
d'enseignement et de recherche de
médecine aéronautique qui prépare
actuellement cette expérience fait les
précédentes expériences effectuées hors
santé à 69,63 ont porté sur des rats et
des chats
nous ont permis de mettre en évidence
quelques formes de france et français
les pro core typographique qui font
penser à des petits phénomènes d'une
émission c'est à dire que le sujet en
état d'apesanteur aurait des états entre
le sommeil et la paye peut-être
peut-être aimé de façon très fugace une
toute façon et si pour cela pour mettre
ceci en évidence que prépare ans
prochaine expérience l'électro corps
typographie représente 500 qu'elle
représente le reflet le plus fidèle du
niveau de vigilance d'un hannibal tv
guide
est ce que vous pensez que certaines
anomalies dans le comportement les
cosmonautes pourrait s'expliquer de la
même strate
oui je pense que oui effectivement le
ce que l'on peut compléter ainsi nos
hypothèses de travail c'est que les
différents classements nantes sont
revenus sains et saufs n'ont pas
présenté de troubles de troubles
importants
toutefois et s'ils ont les peluches de
près les résultats physiologique il
on trouve des certaines anomalies
anomalies à la froide comportement et de
sommeil ainsi dans cette cage de faraday
se trouve un sujet qui subit des mesures
actuellement qui serviront comme de
référence quand plus tard on en verra
dans l'espace qu'elle enregistrements
effectués pour en soi main alors sur le
singe qui se trouve dans la cage le
singe a reçu des électrodes à demeure au
niveau du cerveau et nous avons de haut
en bas sur des cinq premières dérivation
correspondent au cortex bosch
c'est-à-dire l'hémisphère gauche du
cerveau
les cinq suivantes correspondent à
l'hémisphère droit du cerveau l'avoir 11
celle ci correspond à une voix profonde
qui évite au camp nou camp qui est une
structure profonde en relation avec des
phénomènes de veille sur nous mêmes et
mockus les trois voies suivantes sont
démis au drame quand cependant à des
électrodes placées dans les muscles de
la nuque du biceps et du triceps ensuite
devoir de physiologie végétative
l'électrocardiogramme et laurine
respiratoire lorsque l'animal tente à
s'assoupir dix ans les ondes se comptent
plus grandes comme en ce moment je crois
oui en gros cela mais il est évident que
l'on peut voir d'après la forme du tracé
le niveau de vigilance d'un animal c'est
là en damant le but de l'expérience et
nous voyons actuellement l'animal
surveillant en permanence en réalité
division bien l'entendre il animal est
au calme au repos il ne voit personne
il s'habitue à cette version tandis que
nous nous pouvons le voir et nous
pouvons voir un chaque moment s'il a les
yeux verts fermer la tendance à
s'envoler ces animaux ville avec des
électrodes implantées dans le crâne et
ce qui souffre de cela et bien en mains
sûres et il n'est pas possible de voir
des animaux qu'ils puissent souffrir le
comprenais tout de suite parce que si
ces animaux souffrent et il vaudrait
plus rien pour nous
il se rendait en voiture vers sont
égoïstes j'espère qu'ils seraient
perturbés et leur français ne
signifierait plus rien nous allons voir
maintenant la préparation de ces singes
est tout d'abord la première phase vient
en premier en france d'un entraînement
il faut ni le mans entraîné des singes
d'abord à être habillé est fixée sur un
siège spécial ce siège qui simule le
conteneur qui sera placé dans le sujet
et si nous avons dessiné fait exécuter
un acte en particulier pour les fixer
sur ce siège
or la deuxième phase et la préparation
du conditionnement
oui alors le conditionnement il s'agit
évidemment d'une deuxième expérience
pendant une deuxième partie de
l'expérience qui est l'étude d'un geste
psychomoteur d'injuste de coordination
motrice et nous avons habitué ces
animaux a effectué un geste précis c'est
à dire appuyer sur un bouton
un bouton placé au milieu de quatre
autres à un signal donné leur ressemble
à un conte samedi l'appui bien c'est
cela le singe appuyé sur le banc moutons
et il reçoit une récompense et c'est une
pâte de fruits ils en sont friands